good news for fans of equality pay
equity between men and women is at an
all-time highs the bad news however
women on average still make 79 cents to
the dollar more women than ever before
are getting degrees but as education
levels increase the blue gap actually
widens so what can you do well you
cannot have kids women with children on
average see their salaries decreased by
four percent male salaries actually
increase six percent with kids you can
mask your gender resumes with male
sounding names are more likely to get
offers one important study of the
orchestra selection process found that
women were 50% more likely to get
rejected if their gender was revealed
during the audition after the findings
were released most orchestras
implemented a blind audition process
which could be a good template for other
industries to follow you could apply for
a job run by a woman nope in
entertainment male directors hire women
as writers eight percent of the time in
as cinematographers six percent of the
time but when women are the directors
those numbers soar you can just ask for
more money women on average ask for 7 K
less than men however women who ask for
raises are often seen as demanding and
difficult to work with in business
successful startups had twice as many
women in senior positions than
unsuccessful ones in tech at Google
Facebook and Microsoft women average
about 30 percent of the workforce but
only 16 percent of the tech jobs and at
Twitter women are 50 percent of the
workforce but only 10 percent of the
tech jobs in the worst part women have
been proven to write better code a
github study showed that code written by
women was accepted seventy eight point
six percent of the time compared to
seventy four point six percent for men
but as soon as the gender of the female
coder was revealed the acceptance of the
code fell to 62 point five percent while
there are some cracks in the glass
ceiling it's gonna take a few more
wonder women and men to break it